[موسيقى]
تتقدم بموجة من النجاح ،
تنمو هذه الشركة التقنية التركية الناشئة
يومًا بعد يوم وتقدم دروسًا في اللياقة البدنية
تأتي مع سهولة ممارسة
التمارين في أي وقت في أي مكان
من الاستوديو في اسطنبول ، حيث يمكنك
بث جلسات تدريبية حية يومية
، كما تتيح للمشتركين الوصول إلى
مكتبة  من التدريبات المسجلة
، كان الوباء هو الذي دفع
استوديو اللياقة البدنية المجتمعي الكتاب الحضريين
إلى العالم الرقمي ويقول مؤسسوها
إن هذا هو مستقبل العمل
الذي كنا نخطط دائمًا للقيام بشيء
رقمي ، لكن لم يتم التخطيط له في وقت مبكر
مثل ما جلبه الطمع  نحن لذلك قمنا للتو
بتحويل كل قوتنا البشرية
وأدمغتنا وأنت تعرف أي جهد
لدينا للقيام بشيء
رقمي وقمنا حرفيًا بتحويل نموذج أعمالنا بالكامل
إلى نسخة رقمية واليوم
لدينا أكثر من 50000 مستخدم نشط على جهاز
رقمي  منصة أكبر من
خبرتنا المادية التي بنيناها
في السنوات الخمس الماضية
[موسيقى]
لتحويل هذه التجربة المادية  لقد كان التحول
إلى عالم رقمي بمثابة عبء ثقيل
لمدرب الشركة البالغ عددهم 24 مدربًا
في الأشهر القليلة الأولى أو عدة مرات ، فقد
كان يمثل تحديًا حقيقيًا ، ولكن بعد ذلك
أدركت أن القدرة على التكيف هي واحدة من
أهم
المهارات ليس فقط كمدرب كإنسان.
بالطبع ، إن
وجود أشخاص في الفصل يتشاركون
الطاقة معهم أمر لا يصدق ،
لكنني
أنظر أيضًا إلى الكاميرا وأحاول
تخيل وجوههم وأنا وأعتقد أنني في
الواقع أقوم بالوصول إلى المزيد من
الأشخاص من خلال هذه
الأداة وتقول الشركة إنهم  يقول بيركمان ،
مستشار عمليات الاندماج والاستحواذ السابق ،
إن التركيز سيتحول الآن بشكل أكثر
قوة إلى التوسع العالمي ،
لقد أغلقنا للتو جولة أولية لدينا مقابل
مليون دولار
عند تقييم 7 ملايين بعد ذلك ، وهو أمر
رائع.  عدد كبير للشركات الناشئة التركية
مع هذا التمويل ، سننمي
فريقنا ينمو تسويقنا ينمو
وجودنا العالمي ، لقد حصلنا للتو على
استوديو في لوس أنجلوس ومع
Kpis التي وضعناها لأنفسنا
بحلول نهاية العام ، والهدف هو إجراء
جولة أخرى مقابل 3
ملايين بتقييم 30 مليون.
التطبيق الذي يقول إنه لا يوفر
لياقة بدنية مريحة فحسب ، بل إنه أيضًا ميسور التكلفة
بحوالي دولار أمريكي واحد شهريًا.
العملاء الذين حصلوا على الشهر الأول
مقابل أقل من
ليراتين تركيتين ، أي حوالي 10 سنتات ، يقول بيركمان إنه استوحى من العديد من
الشركات الناشئة التركية التي جعلت حجمها كبيرًا
على الساحة العالمية ،
وأعتقد أن تركيا سوق اختبار مذهل
أه بادئ ذي بدء ، فهي مكان رائع
قم بإنشاء منتجك واختبره ، ومن ثم
فإن
تكلفة التعلم منخفضة
جدًا مقارنة بالعديد من
الأسواق التنافسية مثل أوروبا
، وآسيا ، وأيضًا الأشخاص الأتراك
يعملون بجد للغاية وهم
ملتزمون جدًا بما يفعلونه
مع توقيت التمويل المناسب
ويأمل أن يكون التسويق هو
قصة نجاح شركة التكنولوجيا التركية الناشئة القادمة
Gemini Canada لسوق CNN
الشرق الأوسط اسطنبول